alright guys I didn't think I could be
any more excited about this Star Wars
panel and then they handed me this cube
that I get to throw at you at the end of
the panel's so you can use it as a
microphone and ask these guys questions
this is blowing my mind right now I kind
of want to use it for the entire thing
but you probably wouldn't hear me well
enough
I am very Nemiroff with Collider and I
love Star Wars so so much and you are
about to meet two super talented guys
who have been with the franchise for
such a long time not wasting any more
time here let's bring them out we have
Daniel Logan and Matthew Boyd yep I see
him they're coming hey hey I'm gonna put
this down before I do something
dangerous with it let's give her a round
of applause guys hi hi no don't touch it
it's not heads up does it not matter
oh if you say it doesn't matter I'll
change my entire philosophy on that well
my grandmother's restless soul should be
mad if I didn't take it and put in my
pocket every penny saved is a penny
earned every penny on it should be a
penny saved I'll take that as well it's
an earring hmm you know I on the garage
just let me know I'll put it in my
pocket I wanted to start with you right
now Daniel because I was doing my little
bit of research for this panel and you
seem to have a really interesting story
that I want to hear more about in terms
of how you got into acting because it
seems like it was one of those like one
in a million chances well I grew up in
New Zealand where we didn't yet have
Lord the Rings so we had suddenly called
short Lynch Street and every actor in my
country had dreamed to be in Shortland
Street but in my life I need even
dreamed to be in choler Street because I
wanted to play rugby
well I end up playing rugby most of my
life growing up since I was a very very
little boy and my coach ended up getting
an audition for a milk commercial and he
was allowed to put two names down for
the commercial so he puts down my name
and his son's name well I go along and I
end up being I guess too white for the
role but I over talked to casting
director to where they were like I
really like this guy I don't know we'll
get my job so I actually got a land on
the road and it started from there and
the lady she really loved me and she
started hiring me back for more and more
things and then from there I got the
audition to place in Star Wars and it's
funny because I tell people I say when
my agent called me for the role she
called me basically with the humble
ization of you're not gonna get this
role but I will forever be able to sell
you as the little kid that was gonna be
the kid that was in that Star Wars film
just by some God's grace I actually
landed the role and I stumped everyone
my whole entire country probably they're
like wait who so I'm so curious was
there the level of secrecy at that time
that we faced now we're like you hear
that and you can't tell a soul for so so
long yeah my best friend is sitting here
we've been friends since we were 8 years
old so growing up through the whole
process of it all he's seen me growing
from just this normal kid and we raised
growing up you know playing as kids to
now being transported into the world of
Star Wars which has completely not only
changed my life by my whole entire
family's and I had no clue what I was
getting given to be honest I had no clue
what Star Wars was we used to run around
and bushes playing you know shooting cap
guns at each other you know playing a
normal life we didn't get the TV out our
families forced us outside and we were
to play in the forest though my mom
would say go play on the motorway don't
recommend you say that to your kids
you're talking to someone who basically
spent the entire last week of her life
with a VR headset on so I have forgotten
what it's like to be outside VR headset
immersed in Star Wars guys if you have
an opportunity to check out Vader
immortal I highly recommend it you
brought up that you two have been
friends for a long time I'm curious how
did you guys meet we met from Star Wars
yeah I worked I was working at Lucasfilm
when the movie that Daniel was in attack
of the clones is being made so I
remember I had this call because we a
lot of the times what we record on set
the sound did we record on set we
usually George Lucas likes to tinker
with the films and we changed them after
the fact so I got this call we're gonna
have to record this is this kid Dan
Logan as Boba Fett for some new lines
for the film and he's got a lot of
energy that's what I was told and yeah
so with that we met on the film actually
so that's that's almost like 15 16 no I
don't know what that is how many years
ago 2002 and so ever since through the
fan community and projects we've worked
on together so we've known each other
that long yeah about 20 years I've been
that long is it almost yeah it's almost
like it's like 18 years or so I don't
know it's a long long time so that was
the days when you would record right and
it was old technology you remember that
you're like hey hey Daniel could you
hear me and I'm like hey Daniel can you
hear me you hear the echo because it's
going all the way the new zealand's from
from Skywalker Ranch but delay yeah no I
okay on the third beep make sure you hit
the line right then Thanh ways here dad
Todd Lee's here okay that sucked can we
do another one ha ha I would have said
that was good
can we do another one I get those
average get better so just in case you
guys don't know not only did Daniel play
Boba Fett but you are also the voice of
General Grievous so yes this might be
more difficult for you than you but I'm
curious if you could pick one admirable
quality about the character you play
that you really like what would it be
and why an admirable quality he's kind
of I guess he's got a lot of pride is
that admirable I don't know that's the
thing with the villainous character it's
one thing to be a cookie cutter
one dimension it's another to have a
villain that like really believes in his
agenda
he's pretty frustrated I think he's
given you know and we've expanded upon
his character in the Clone Wars series
with Dave Filoni and all that but I
think that Grievous was always out to
prove something you know he never was he
never knew the force so it wasn't quite
a Jedi but he understood the technical
abilities about how to use lightsabers
he his army that it was given was
basically a bunch of useless droids
which I also voiced those guys all the
battle droids army as well so that was
also fun but he yeah he's got a lot of
pride got a lot of got a lot to prove
but he is basically a coward in many
ways but I just channel that into the
performance frustration yeah he would be
a badass chef yes with the forearms you
know what most people don't know but
Matt actually has an interesting story
into the world of Star Wars too and the
day he told me I never forgot it and I
thought it was fantastic from actually
being a video game tester yeah I started
I started working for Lucasfilm when I
was 17 it's a while ago I was a video
games tester I found I found it there
was a job for a Quality Assurance
technician as what they called them in
this little town called Nicasio
California and I knew that that was
probably where they hid this hidden
fortress of Skywalker Ranch was this is
before you could Google map it just find
it but I got this job up there and it's
because my dad had a fax machine this is
1989 and my dad had a fax machine and I
found out what the fax number of
Lucasfilm was and I faxed my resume when
I was still in high school my resume my
damn to my dad I was like what should I
put on my resume dad I'm you know 16
years old I don't know put all the video
games you play so I just typed all the
videogames out put them in there and
then I put all my facts about what I
what I am capable of doing and then
my dad's like you should put an extra
like extra facts about yourself you know
personal facts I wrote in excellent
health living with parents living with
parents but somehow my facts the resume
to Lucasfilm and I got a call back and
they're like hello is this Matthew wood
yeah they're like did you fax your
resume to us I'm like yes I did they're
like no one's ever done that we've been
talking about it in the office all day
we'd like you to come down and have an
interview so I showed up and I got this
interview hey do you still have that fax
number hilarious it's like bringing in a
closet somewhere what were you doing in
that position was there a specific day
yeah it was I showed up they gave me the
address the Skywalker Ranch my dad had
to drive me out there I didn't have a
car yet I loved my dad he was amazing I
love your dad to be amazing so he drove
me out there and I walked in and I was
like oh I better look fancy what should
I do this is nine through the late 80s
and I'm like okay I'll wear my best bolo
tie and my cool like vest that kind of
looks like bono from u2 I'll wear that
I'll slick my hair back and I remember I
walked in and all that that I was this
little building called the carriage
house it's an Skywalker this is in the
games division was you know forty people
maybe and I start walking down the path
and I see all these like guys like geeky
guys like I am but I thought I should
look fancy but they're all you know
t-shirts drinking coke sitting there
looking at me like as I'm walking like
who is this guy but then I walked in and
and I was able to you know talk Tech
with everybody and talk we all played
the same games and and I made it I guess
a good impression and I got a call back
to come back and start working there at
Skywalker Ranch to test videogames my
first game I tested was The Secret of
Monkey Island which is this wonderful
game and then they've reassured it
actually if you ever want to play that
it's a fun game written really early in
the LucasArts history but but yeah so I
did that so I was a videogames tester
yeah
guys both have like an amazing
one-in-a-million story your first big
opportunity like that that's so cool
Daniel I want to know what you're
thinking about some of the new stuff
coming our way the mandalorian because
you know we were we were all expecting
maybe Boba Fett to have something to do
with I don't know a feature film or have
some sort of involvement in that show so
what is it you think about the show and
what it turned out to be that made that
the right path for Star Wars on TV well
you could understand the character Boba
Fett wasn't force-fed on every single
moment and every single scene of Star
Wars and we can't just come and redo
that and then take that all away right
away the Mandalorian for me being raised
in the convention world the 500 first
have had a really great response to the
Lucasfilm and and the respect that they
have given as fans to the company
Mandalorian mercs I was I think the
first the one of the first people as an
honorary member and I was very honoured
you know there's all of like maybe 50
members 15 years ago and they've worked
and worked and worked to establish not
only the name as the Mandalorian mercs
but as a fan group and a big lovers of
not just Boba Fett the character but the
Mandalorians and the Mandalorians that
he came from and he worshiped and he
wanted to obviously represent so for
that now that the Mandalorians have a
place that we can explore you start to
understand why the fet started to be
attracted to that Mandalorian lifestyle
why they dressed as the Mandalorians and
took on that you know homage I guess but
decreed but the Mandalorian doesn't have
to be the Mandalorian and have Boba Fett
in every single episode I think the fact
is is with all the new directors and
everything like that and exploring the
world of the Mandalorian you guys are
going to get so much that we weren't
promised unfortunately from my god
George Lucas he said alright I'm gonna
do six and
and he gave you one more which was the
Clone Wars okay to the holiday special
but you guys got the Clone Wars the
birth of Boba Fett is the holiday
special so yeah that's why I love them I
love the holiday special I wanted to
build one I told everybody about the
holiday special then everyone else
started building it before me I'm an
idiot what you just said though is one
of the coolest things about Star Wars
world building is that maybe Boba Fett
isn't front-and-center like some have
hoped in the Mandalorian but by
exploring Mandalorian culture in that
then we can go back and watch Boba Fett
and other pieces of material and have
more depth in layers to him which is the
coolest thing and with Disney I think
that their understanding that they have
to make long charity out of it because
there's generations after generations
you guys have done it to them you bridge
your kids to love Star Wars - and these
kids are gonna breed their kids to the
left Style Wars - so you can't blame
them so no I think it's just about
figuring out what the fans want how to
cater to that but also stay true to the
storylines and their backstories that we
once had as well speaking of all the new
material we have gotten already what is
your favorite part about the newest
generation of Star Wars and what are you
hoping to see down the line I feel like
yeah I mean you know you kind of know
stuff yeah well I'm working on a lot of
the new stuff and for me that's more
well yeah right the best part of it is
just been you know cuz I started with
George Lucas just like we both did and
now getting to work with new directors
and new people that come in to work at
Lucasfilm and they're given this amazing
toolbox of your Skywalker Sound which is
where I work I do all the sound on the
film so here's Skywalker Sound here's
Industrial Light and Magic and here's
the dug chain here's the story group and
here's this group of people that are
dedicated to this craft of Star Wars and
now this director gets to put their own
spin on it and and under the guise of
are under the direction of Kathleen
Kennedy in our story group so that's
been fun to see every new director come
in and they're wide-eyed fans I mean
each one of them JJ Abrams Rian Johnson
Gareth Edwards all of them come in and
they're very just I can't believe I get
to play in this universe so that's been
really satisfying for me and we're just
making a whole lot of new stuff
so unhappy about the direction we've
gone and I'm happy about what we've done
and all the different variety and
excited to see where we go into the
streaming world this d-plus
system that we're putting together for
that'll happen oh yeah right it'll have
the mandalorian and clone wars and all
that so there's all there's a whole lot
coming down the pipe that's very
exciting and as a fan myself it's it's
been gratifying to work on them all
going back to something you just said
I'm curious your opinion on this having
worked with so many different directors
do you think it's important for a Star
Wars feature film director to be a fan
because I was also just i believe i was
watching or reading something with ron
howard where he said he was approaching
it more as like a casual fan like do you
think you need to know the ins and outs
in order to drive one of these movie i
don't think you need i mean working with
ron howard on solo was one of the my
favorite experiences ever working in
film the man is a consummate
professional totally understands that
filmmaking is actually fun what we do
we're working on movies we're not you
know having to save lives or something
we're like working on films and he
understands we all have a life outside
of the job so he lets us hat you know we
don't work a lot of overtime and you
know the first time I met him I'd met
him a couple of times
socially but the first time I met him
professionally we sat down and had this
great meeting about what he wanted the
movie to be and he says he would give a
lot of trust and the artist saying you
know we'd get into his own here's the
story points I want to hit and I'm
trusting you guys to guide me that it's
in the Star Wars pantheon that it's
gonna if there's something that I could
do the tweak it to make it just right
for Star Wars I'm entrusting upon the
story group and all these artists that
are working with me to bring us there
and so they don't need to be they don't
need to know every single planet and
name of every single person but there's
a group of people our Seleucus film
story group and the artists of work on
the film's that are there to do that for
him and so but you can have other fans
that completely know it like Dave Filoni
that I work with like the you know he's
completely he's been trained from George
Lucas and he's an uber fan so he knows
everything so that's a bonus so that's
just all it's it's it you can do it any
other way any way you want but Ron
super professional and one of my
favorite experiences and yet I think
casual fan is a good way to say that
yeah you guys have name-dropped so many
cool people from Kathleen Kennedy to
George Lucas to Dave Filoni as well is
there anyone kind of on that tier of the
Star Wars franchise that has ever given
you a piece of advice about telling a
Star Wars story that's really stuck with
you well Phil O'Neill Ickes and George
both were very much they like to tie
things and submit they're very much into
the the Joseph Campbell power of myth
and restore the the story of the hero's
journey and all that so when you can tie
your story into something that's greater
than that moment they're very much into
that that's that's that's one of the big
pieces of advice that I've been given
and and when we try to you know you we
did all the even though I work in sound
it's still a very inclusive project and
I'm having to re-record a bunch of the
actors and and and you can come up
especially a lot of characters that have
masks on like stormtroopers like Boba
Fett like kylo Ren you can change your
dialogue to fit better at later on in
post-production so there's a lot of Star
Wars movies are made in post-production
a lot of it the editorial process the
visual effects the sound the music it's
all done after the shooting so it's all
honing that film and to tell the story
that the director wanted with sound and
visual effects so lotta after after
you've shot yeah just about the same
amount of time it's about it's about a
year's worth of posts that you do on a
movie a film you post for me I never
realized at the time being so young and
not knowing what Star Wars was when I
became full effect I was getting taught
by the man himself the author the
Creator the one man George Lucas and
although he didn't spend much time
giving directions to the other adults he
spent a lot of time showing me and
teaching me what he wanted me to see
like instead of being like oh hey you're
gonna be flying a spaceship and there's
gonna be like these rocks coming at ya
he's like oh so you're gonna come back
next week and we're gonna fly through an
asteroid and there's gonna be these
boulders that are gonna come
when there's gonna be a Jedi chasing you
and you guys is gonna be flying after me
can you do that I'm like how cool is
this job right
so now being a grown man and having a
kid of my own I look back at those
experiences in that time not realizing
that I had something a one-on-one
interaction connection with this one man
that you know many people would never
ever get now especially in the Star Wars
world you know and I will forever be out
of dying and and take every single
direction and and what he helped me to
bring Boba Fett to life onstage jumping
off something Matthew said before I'm
wondering did you ever do like a line
that was then drastically changed in
post like what's the biggest difference
from something like day one when you
recorded it to the final product well we
did one scene where I opened the door
and then you know where my big forehead
comes in my five head comes into play
zip oh boy is your father here I
actually sit nope the first time around
but after post we decided to change it
to yep and then my dad got his head
chopped off no that's a big change
change the whole story we went in
Episode three
it was Jango Fett Boba Fett you know
Padme love story another one love story
number two no I don't really remember
you know we did so much I remember when
I was doing the clone scene and I was
standing next to myself and I'd have to
pretend like I'm talking to myself and I
said to George like what do I say to
myself and he's like well um just ask
yourself what's better like a yeah I
guess for I like add some kind of
airplane or another kind of airplane and
I had no clue what kind of airplane
these were right but I'm like saying it
to myself when my stuff's not even
standing there and I'm like still had no
clue but when you watch the movie it
looks really good
it looks like I'm asking the other one
like hey so how's education coming along
I wasn't negative enacted to create
words I asked the director we've been
talking a lot about sound here so I have
a feeling it's important to point out
that you are an Academy Award nominated
sound editor I think four times over
yes four times four words project so I
know this is just a common question we
get asked pretty often at Collider and
it is specifically what exactly does a
supervising sound editor yeah well
there's probably a laundry list of
things that what is success
yeah I don't I sound editing so I'm here
basically trying to tell the story that
the director wants with sound so it's
everything that you hear in the
soundtrack except for music so -
obviously that's done by the composer
and John Williams and so we take we read
the script till we go through the movie
and we say here are some things we could
add to give an expansiveness to the to
the to the project and Star Wars that's
huge because it's always everything's
created and see a lot of CG so you have
to come up with new ships and new
creatures and new weapons and new
ambiences for planets and and then we
have you're basically trying to tell the
story make it more expansive than it
looks on screen and sound has this great
ability to do that because it's
subconscious I mean you don't see it
you're hearing it you're feeling it so
it's highly emotional and how we can
manipulate your senses to be able to
feel scared or or feel relief or feel
claustrophobic or expanded and you're
and what you're looking at is just all
in the sounds that we've picked and
chosen and never you don't really want
to ever stand out is they had the
featured element but in these theaters
now where we can do Dolby Atmos sound
where their speaker's above you and in
front of you and all around you and the
low frequencies it gives us a big
soundstage to work with and we work on
the Star Wars films for about a year or
creating all this and we put all kinds
of crazy things in there because it's
all fiction I mean that everything is we
can create so as long as it's
synchronized with the action that you're
seeing on screen when something happens
and we put a sound to go with that the
brain attaches those things together and
believes that that is the sound that
that thing is making so that's a huge
part of the job is there an instance
where you got to the right sound for
something and it was like a really
unusual tool or path to get there yeah
all the time I mean sometimes we'll Rick
poor things out in the field that might
just sound cool I'll be like somewhere
like you know in the airport I was in
yesterday I heard this little scooter
was bringing somebody late to their
plane and I had this really cool sound I
ran after it with my microphone to try
to get it you know it's just to put it
into a movie but a lot of it like when I
was we shot those the prequels in
Australia in Sydney and so when I was
there I was there on the set working
with the production mixer and making
sure we were getting the right material
but then Ben Burtt who's my mentor an
amazing sound designer who created the
sounds of Chewbacca and r2d2 and all the
lasers and all that he was go explore
Australia and go grab some sounds so I
went up to the rainforest up in northern
Queensland and I recorded fruit bats in
the sanctuary and they were fighting
over a banana so I recorded that and
then we went down all the way to
Melbourne and I went to a penguin
sanctuary and recorded all these penguin
mating calls these Antarctic penguins
that were coming back in from being our
tactics of Melbourne recorded that so I
brought those back to the studio and you
don't really know what you're gonna do
with those things but we kind of played
with them and that became the sound of
the Geonosian aliens and the in the in
the big arena battle so like the crowd
or the mating penguins and then when
they're attacking Anakin that's the
fruit bats fighting over the banana so
that that kind of material like once you
put it in sync with the picture it works
and you're never seen ever again so
that's just an example of things that
you'd put into the movie like that that
would make that work because yeah it's
just aliens are weird
Daniel I want you to listen to I'm just
saying they're the same cargo but I feel
like it's it's like a missed opportunity
to not do some sort of weird con soon
right now that you can then record and
put your next stops right yeah is that
you McCoy on you right I know and you're
gonna meet that challenge I feel like we
can't do anything awkward enough I want
you to weigh in on this cat being a
hundred and first Boba Fett what what's
happening oh yeah you want me to weigh
in I said I wanna see five pounds Wow
nice you wear it well that was a good
way to like get her
a very curious question question I mean
it's not really a question I kind of
left it open-ended because I'm not sure
how to ask you like who's dead Oh
to be continued and here's one for you
Matthew that you probably won't be able
to answer actually you know what rather
than ask you about rise of Skywalker
nothing the the final film how about the
one piece of it we have seen did you
have anything to do with the laugh at
the ends of the trailer it was sound
wasn't it
so probably yeah I can't obviously I
can't I've worked for the company for
almost 30 years and that's because I
don't talk but what happens have you
heard any horror stories um well I did
actually say something recently in the
thirty years that I've worked for the
company it was its celebration we were
having an interview on one of the sound
stages or one of the stages about
something like what's going on as
Skywalker what are you working on I'm
working on this and this and this and
this and I said something that I was
working on that I wasn't supposed to say
which has been announced now but and it
was like and then it would just hit read
it like crazy and I got a call like yeah
we can't talk about that project we have
an announced too yet oh my god I'm so
sorry
stop beta just shows up in your office
like yeah pretty much yeah they had the
road wide basically happens but I've
been pretty dang good thirty years I
think to have one slight amount weapons
malfunction is fine could you imagine me
13 years old getting the movie star wars
and having to be quiet there's all these
pretty girls right and I'm like hey how
you doing they're like no like I would
have been the best pick-up line you
don't understand I'm gonna hit the big
screen soon I promise you want to be
with me the temptation is real I would
feel that if I were in your shoes all
right do we want to throw this cube out
into the audience who wants to ask a
question anyone have questions I kind of
like I'm happy it's someone really far
away exciting I want to like throw this
cubes Andrew alright if you're like in
the line of fire please watch out what's
that
do not uh if you do get hurt in the
process of this do it no lawsuits or hey
you want me to throw it wow that guy's
that was a sucker throw right side row
yeah what's a soccer throw yeah so I the
Mike in that thing oh the beauty of
incredible so I I really like the noise
that the sonic imploder makes yeah so -
what's your favorite sound from Star
Wars great question uh yeah the seismic
charges or do we call them sonic charges
on camera because if you look at Ewan
McGregor's lips in that scene he's
actually not saying well because we
rewrote it I think he said seismic
charge but we made him say sonic charge
does he say sonic charge in the final
film sonic charges stand by or whatever
he says yes yes so that was a fun that
was actually the absence of sound makes
that call because it was a bit there was
a moment where the flash happened and we
kept saying Ben Burtt was like what do
we put in there what do we put in there
there's this cool flash we have the
explosion sound that we already know
that we like and then we came up with
why don't we put and when we put nothing
in there so it actually goes to like
nothing and then it blows up and we that
movie caused all these people like when
we were doing the quality assurance
check on the film and you know everyone
has to watch it a million times to make
sure we've got it done right there like
there's a drop out in the movie it goes
to nothing there's a silent drop out in
the movie there's a problem with it we
meant to do that
same thing on so on Episode eight when
we did the whole thing when hold o
sacrifices herself into the fleet we
went to quiet for many seconds on that
one and they actually had to distribute
us a pamphlet with all the film saying
that's not an error it's on purpose that
it goes silent I love that moment cuz
when we premiered the movie I went in to
see it and at that moment when she does
that it goes quiet you can hear everyone
in the audience like gasping and who do
you hear all the people in the audience
freaking out and then the big explosion
happens that's actually a lot of episode
eight has a lot of my favorite stuff but
one of my favorite things to work on
when the prequels was the was the
the podrace just because there were so
many different vehicles and George
wanted each pod to represent a different
creatures so they had to have a very
distinct personality so I got to go
around all over the world and record jet
boats and and race cars and helicopters
and all kinds of like a Porsche engine
that someone had punctured a hole in
their muffler and like all kinds of
weird stuff to get all those those pod
sounds that's one of my fan also John
Williams whose amazing and obviously and
creates incredible work sat the first
lap of the pod race out so he didn't it
was completely all of our sound effects
we got to focus on until the second rat
lap so that was a huge fun project for
me it was the pod race episode one do
you have a favorite sound yeah when my
dad got his head chopped off that there
you go yes that was another silent
moment everyone else was like whoo and
I'm like yes he's gone I'm in I'm next
bet I'm the baddest bounty hunter in the
galaxy how do I get the jetpack on a
lighter note ever since force awakens
came out my ringtone on my phone has
been bb-8 obv it's so wonderful when
that goes off there's just like a little
bit of joy it adds to my life BB it's
amazing I love bb-8 you add joy to my
life to your delightful he's got the
best sneaker collection you guys should
just know that though some blue suede
shoes right there I'm very impressed I'm
not gonna step on them but I kind of
want there's some nice boots do though
if you want to toss that cube to the
next person with a question we just need
a hand raised so he has like somewhere
to find there we go if you injured it oh
it's broken
mic-check okay one two sibilance like
chick okay a quick question so my kids
are obsessed with porks I know it's not
the most favorite animal in the boards
but if you guys had to way he walks
porks and I don't really know what the
prequel equivalent of animals would be
maybe like the EOP meant that to Salado
which one would you
is the superior of animals if these
smiles right there I mean it's got to be
the pork it's the poor thank you yeah
I don't know as a bounty hunter chewy
loves pogs
so I wanna have to go with what's this
Ewok
what's the secret behind the sound of
the pork
what is it the porks are actually three
different sounds it's uh it's some
chickens at Skywalker Ranch we have a
farm there actually it's got like a
ranch so it's chickens there and then
they're not so cool anymore huh and its
value to people saying Oh like pork
tastes like chicken
yeah that's true they do then it's also
the sound of a turkey call it's a turkey
call sound and then there's one more in
there we actually did a little sound
documentary you can find online ABC news
did it was about the sound of episode 8
we actually feature the porks as part of
that we show how we made them yeah you
find it online thank you
how they made him and how they ate him
can you do a pork sound you know how to
do a pork sound let's hear it in the mic
come on there we go yes I got a chewy
for you let's hear the chewy
[Applause]
who can top that you get the cube next
okay next on the fix we got one right up
here oh there we go
here we go yes oh yes got it success
you're the question you have to ask us a
question
you're either asking a question or you
make a sound Tusken Raiders Tusken
Raiders for you what did you think of
the nerf that General Grievous got
compared to tortoise keys version
compared to the oh yeah yeah how is
portrayed in the Tarte au Ski clone wars
I look at that and a lot of us at
Lucasfilm do look at it as like a very
adrenaline hyper version of clone wars I
mean because they were you know a little
two minutes stories that we did which I
loved they're incredible and they were
just as a very superhero version of that
that was fit for the medium of a two
minute it's you know and when we did
Clone Wars we realized that with our the
the later the 3d animated one which were
going to be 22 minutes long I think it
was I don't think the energy of that
tartar ski version could be kept up over
a hundred episodes you just everyone
would be exhausted how would you do that
but but but that's kind of I mean also
the the way in the format it was drawn
in certainly lends itself to a lot of
that action and I love that series I
think it was fantastic so but seeing how
ILM visioned Grievous and their version
of it for the theatrical II was pretty
impressive too and how flow needed it
for Clone Wars as well they're all
different and also I just did a bunch
for battlefront 2 so they've got
Grievous in there and he's got all these
crazy new moves that are pretty amazing
like this crab walk is pretty terrifying
so it's as I said like each director has
their own interpretation of how they
want to do it each format you know fits
to that that character and how you
display them but I think they're all
great yeah oh we got one more question
go ahead boy
yes yes yes if George Lucas was coughing
yes when we recorded that part George
Lucas himself had a really bad cough
that day and I gestured to my friend who
was recording me does George kept coming
up to the mic and giving me direction
and you know standing up because that's
where the script was so he'd come up and
him telling me direction he'd start
coughing he to move himself away from
the mic
and I moved back because it was pretty
frightful cough and I moved back and
then I looked at my friend and I keep
rolling keep rolling and so we recorded
a bunch of George's coughs for that and
I had no idea that that COFF was gonna
be part of the character but I said when
I sent all because I had to process all
the sounds to make him sound like
they're coming out of that little
speaker in his mouth I sent that up to
George including the coughed and he
ended up putting that in and then I
snuck in a couple of his own coughs as
well so some of those coughs have
Grievous are George Lucas which is
amazing you've got all these fans I mean
like you didn't want to suck George
Lucas's coughs in it it would have to be
sick of it just look at all those germs
would make me so creative in my face
just give it to me I'll take no no
unfortunately not so are we asking a
question and or a sound effect from Star
Wars now I won't be you on the spot
first I would say that would be an
amazing TV series of you going around
recording things people like how they
were made second thing obviously we want
to bow a movie yes of course
everybody everyone wants a fellow movie
even Dan Logan I think from both of you
being obvious hardcore fans what side
story of a me
character's backstory would you like to
see me like we have you know the Han
Solo movie what would you like to see as
far as you know like a side story of a
character for Star Wars yeah the rancor
keeper I think have I want to know I
know he's had such a sad and he was so
sad how did he come to live like in and
if he was so sad that must have been he
must have had great joy you can only
have that kind of sadness with
experiencing great joy in your life so
I'm gonna say the rancor keepers life
with I don't know what their I mean I'm
sure that rancor even had a name like
Sally or something I don't know what the
right course name but that relationship
or the rancor keeper and you know having
to live underneath Jabba the Hutt's
palace but you know hey that's your big
day you're gonna get to fight a Jedi now
and and then and then tragedy strikes I
want to know more about that story I
really do I don't think Disney's gonna
go for that but maybe animate it may be
animated or something yeah I got a way
better way so we do a General Grievous
movie with two extra roms he's actually
working the canteen there and he's been
hiding out from the other Jedi's for a
couple of generations right six arms
grievous as a bartender well he'd be
very happy wash the dishes cut off
fruits veggies
cream milk at the same time or it's like
between the battles for Grievous what he
does in his free time with all those
extra are obvious so then what he does
is he throws down his waist to the solid
pit which his bow was hanging out
favorite place to chill you know also
hiding out
same kind of thing but then I also get
big and fat and fit so when I come out I
look more like a job of the hots tail so
that I disguise with the rest of the
other Jabba's and nice I like this story
somehow I don't think Disney's gonna go
for either of our stories but maybe
that's why I just do sound and you act I
just yeah that I guess no but you know
what backstory would like to see the
boat of the Jango Fett origin film
because we got given his father and
there was so much love for Bober it
would good it'd be cool to go backwards
and explore the jango fett series and
see well where did this guy come from
why did he choose to have a clone child
why didn't he go out with Sam Wizzle who
was hot as heck until she went to an
alien um well I'm getting our track
again na that's good that'll be good a
change Lincoln yeah do a lot of budget
if Boba was a changeling right well sure
I'm the only character that's actually a
female and a male as a Lego character do
you know that I don't know this story
but I'm sure we're gonna hear it as
little boba fett they obviously don't
recreate out of here so they took all
the hair from the girl Legos and let's
vote but young Boba Fett's hair so I
just tell people young boat was the best
character for a boy or girl you got a
boy or girl go you keep thinking run boy
you take the hair off easy Lego no one's
gonna be mad boys might want to turn her
on that's what I want
hold o like know better after her
sacrifice and what is in that lay a
prequel book yes that character is a
rich history that should be yes I agree
I love what about uncle Owen it's kind
of oh that's kind of a sad he was
egerton right um one of the young
version and then he turns into Ian Brown
was that his name I can't remember but
that yeah he definitely got really oh
you want to go that far back I mean
let's do the back stories of Casius
fence yeah oh yeah how do you know that
guy I don't know who's Cassie is fast
kasia's Fett was my grandfather Fett he
was the original fence so you're going
back a lot of you see he's gone my house
on hello dad your local speaking oh yeah
whoa oh yeah we have Boba Fett stories
all day okay we have three minutes next
did you have a follow-up
I saw you want to add something before
no I personally want to
backstory yeah I'm into that yeah
please somebody for anyone question why
did the cube the little guy you got it
the little guy in front well no white
house no question all right
white hat why not yes speaking Czech
yeah sibilance one - what - so you
mentioned that you started with
Lucasfilm doing Quality Assurance for
their video games
yes sir was it kind of just like a
sporadic decision for you to voice
Grievous was it like oh we don't have
any one or with like who could we get
there's nobody that little pimply kid 17
no I I was it was later I did that later
but I worked in the company for another
15 years until that happened but it went
from I was a videogames tester and then
George Lucas was this building he wanted
to build a way to do the prequel movies
and we worked on this show called there
was a show called the young Indiana
Jones chronicles that we did and so we
took a lot of the technology that we
built in that and he wanted to a
completely digital and new so he went to
the video games division and he said
give me your best tester the guy that's
breaking things the most and you know
seems to be into it the most so they
promoted me to work on the sound
division George was making a program
called sound droid and it was a
nonlinear editing program for sound
which hadn't didn't exist before so I
came in and to test that and try to make
it work and luckily for me I was really
but I did really well at that and then
that technology sort of overtook the
industry and so I got a chance to get in
really early on the ground floor to do
that and at the same time I was acting I
was doing like community theater plays I
was an I was a actor at the American
Conservatory Theater in San Francisco so
I I just had that bug but I also had
this job at Lucasfilm which I was not
gonna give up and that was my you know
bread and butter and a dream so I did
that and then voice acting just sort of
was an extension of that and there was a
moment where he was casting that
character and he had put we put 50
different voices in there to try it he
wasn't getting what he wanted and so I I
knew what he wanted and I put my own
audition in under another name
because I didn't that want George to
think of me that way so I Jedi
mind-trick George Lucas to give me the
role
I thought so yeah that's how that
happened yeah over 15 years behind you
we have one minute so we can get one
more question if someone I got a
question before has the question can we
hear the voice oh okay you sing happy
birthday to me that's a lot of lines
that's a lot of lines how about Sohee we
open the movie he says what's the
situation captain I'm gonna do all the
other guys that all go like now look out
Roger Roger that's me too I do all those
guys so there you go what's your
favorite question what's our favorite
question character please I mean mines
Boba Fett way Boba Fett why do we want
to do the job well cuz we get to come to
meet people like you and come to these
amazing events no it's a I love my job
it's at Star Wars I grew up with it I
loved it like crazy and it and it's
allowed me to travel the world and meet
all kinds of fun people and it's a total
icebreaker when you say oh I work on
Star Wars most people know what that is
and I'm not a face actor so I can have a
normal life and live my life completely
normal and not have to be stopped on the
street or anything like that but I can
work on big films and it's a fun a
really fun job and I have an amazing
crew people at Skywalker Ranch that I
work with so I love it there you go I
couldn't of said it better
hi get to be myself don't have very many
friends so I love to be out talk to you
guys and let my ADHD run wild without
being in trouble getting sent to my room
so I thank you guys put it out with me
love you all thank you for coming
convention listen to our stories have a
wonderful week thank you guys so so much
congratulations on everything we can't
wait to see what's coming up next yes
Brighton West bits - may the force be
with you all yes